cloud computing is developing in a way I
think very few of us expected
you know when the concepts of cloud
computing first developed we saw miss
very different than the traditional data
center so it's like Amazon and Google
and Rackspace you know building these
data centers you know away and you could
buy Elastic Compute etc etc and then you
had the traditional data center and so
there's been an ongoing dialogue for the
last several years well winner people
are going to move to the cloud is that
going to be the predominant model what I
think we're actually finding now is
those models are converging there is
going to be no is this a cloud
application is this something that's in
a traditional data center a lot of
exciting things happening about how
applications are being built and
deployed around containers and
elasticity on-premise when you talk
about a lot of those things but
fundamentally what we're seeing is a
hybrid model developing the largest
companies that I talked to so very very
large companies will typically say I
like public cloud to do development
tests or applications that I don't know
what their initial demands going to be
and let them burst out for a while and
they may get small again and I may want
to tear them down and they like public
cloud for that because it's easy to
spool up new compute network storage
power it's easy to scale it's easy to
pull it down but what I also hear from
those same large enterprises
Wow once that applications up and
running and I have a sense of you know
how much compute resources is going to
require and I have a good sense of is
that gonna vary much it's much cheaper
to run in my traditional data center so
I think the big problem now that people
are struggling with with containers and
other technologies is how do I build an
application portfolio that may run in
the cloud but may also run in a very
traditional data center and how do you
build a structure a to build
applications that can run across those
models and but also to monitor them and
manage them and decide when is this more
appropriate to run a public cloud and
when is it more appropriate to run in a
private cloud or in a traditional
infrastructure so I think the whole
bifurcation of cloud versus not what
we're finding is it's all one thing it's
a continuum and people are different
places on that continuum
even with different implications in the
same portfolio of applications in the
same Enterprise IT shop